or professional boundaries it doesn't
respect
sort of uh academic or
or political limits it really requires
a kind of systemic and
cross-disciplinary approach and and
that's why suddenly
science and and the arts uh
technology and design finds itself in
this new
hybrid institution uh trying to address
uh sustainability in in the build
environment
our cities and buildings constitute 40
of the carbon emissions so you can say
they are a very very big part of the
problem
which also means that they are
inevitably a major part
of the solution so um
uh this is where this is where the the
new european bauhaus comes in and and we
have prepared this little
uh video to introduce some of the main
main ideas of
of the european bauhaus this is the new
european bauhaus
a movement that wants to shape the
beautiful sustainable
and inclusive living spaces of tomorrow
a project of hope
brings a cultural dimension the green
deal
and wants to accelerate the transition
of the built environment
too ambitious not if we do it together
that's the plan until summer 2021
we collect your examples ideas and
challenges
to re-imagine future ways to live
together while protecting our planet
your inputs will be translated into
community support
calls for proposals and funding
opportunities including prizes
as from september 2021 we will launch
pilot projects in different eu countries
we will promote
knowledge sharing and will bring our
community to the next level
the new european bauhaus has a global
dimension
and the movement shall spread to all
europe and beyond
are you a designer architect engineer
scientist student entrepreneur or
creative mind
then join the movement and be part of
the new european bauhaus
[Music]
[Music]
so um now i am deeply honored to present
to you
the initiator of the european bauhaus
uh the president of the european
commission
uso la vandalen who launched this new
great initiative
in september last year the president
cannot be here in person because she is
also at the same time
an active participant in the earth
summit so i give you the president of
the european commission
dear presidents dear francesca and
bjarke
ladies and gentlemen there are
moments in time where it's good to take
a minute to reflect
we rush from one emergency to another
we put all our efforts to get as fast as
possible out
of the crisis this is true for vaccines
and the health situation
as well as for the economic and social
recovery
but let's take a minute to look beyond
the pandemic
let us ask ourselves the question
how can we create new perspectives
how can we stimulate hope creativity
and innovation and how can we address
what is by far the most serious crisis
for our planet
the one that has not stopped because of
the pandemic
and i'm talking of course of the climate
crisis
this is what the new european bauhaus
is all about it's about hope
it's about inspiration it's about
new perspectives
and it's about concrete actions against
climate change
and this conference comes exactly at the
right moment
let me talk for one minute about one of
the greatest europeans of our times
robert schumann one of the founding
fathers
of our european community
back in 1954
when europe was still suffering from the
consequences of the war
he wrote and i quote
europe it's essential to work on the
economic recovery
to guarantee military security and to
organize
us politically but
what would all these efforts be worth
if we were not able to build at the same
time
solid and deep cultural relations
between the european countries
that's how we form the european spirit
and all the rest will follow
end of robert quote
had understood one of the keys of the
success
of the european project politics and
economy are necessary but not sufficient
we need more we need a common narrative
it must reach not only our brain but
also our hearts
and our souls we need to be able to
feel it the new
european bauhaus wants to create
precisely this
feeling for our european green deal
with the new european bauhaus we want to
make the european green deal
tangible and palpable
we want to add a cultural dimension
to the economic and technological
transformation
this is essential to achieve the
overarching goal
making europe the first climate neutral
continent by 2050
and thus reconciling
our way of life with nature
to get there we need both a real
transformation of our economy and
society
and a debate about how we can live in
respect of nature and our planet
the historical bauhaus was founded in
weimar and dessau it turned into a
worldwide movement
and this did not happen by chance
some ingredients of what made the
historical bauhaus a success
can also be an inspiration for the new
european bauhaus
and let me mention three
the first ingredient the historical
bauhaus
was created in a time of profound
transformation
people were facing the challenges of
industrialization
gropius and the founders wanted to
respond
to the emerging needs of a new era
they aimed for solutions that were
functional
affordable but also beautiful
with this principle in mind they shape
buildings
fabrics and furniture they always
aimed higher than just innovative design
and the new european bauhaus is also
striving
for this mix of aesthetics
and affordability but we want to add
another element sustainability
because the new european bauhaus wants
to match
sustainability with style
now the second ingredient
the historical bauhaus boldly promoted
new materials like
steel and cement today
we also need to look into new building
materials
but this time it's about sustainability
it's about materials that need less co2
in their production process
the new european bauhaus wants to
accelerate
the transition of the built environment
it wants to scale up nature-based
materials
to support circular design and
architecture
buildings are responsible for 40 percent
of our energy consumption and if we
manage
to change this we have a chance to keep
global warming below 1.5 degrees
the winners for the recently awarded
pritzker prize for architecture
showed how this can be done this price
for the first time in
46 years was awarded
not for new buildings but for
refurbishment
the architects anne lacton and
jean-philippe wassel upgraded
social housing buildings in bordeaux
by making them more energy efficient and
more beautiful because
european cities should capture co2
instead of producing it and yes this
is possible yes we can turn our cities
into urban forests
and the third important element from the
historical bauhaus
is interdisciplinarity
we want to convene people from different
backgrounds and with different
competences to share
and grow their ideas and visions
we can create a better tomorrow if
culture
and technology innovation and
design go hand in hand
it's an honor to have so many brilliant
speakers with us today and tomorrow
for our new european bauhaus we need all
of you
politicians be it in the european
parliament
or in the rural areas and cities of our
union
scientists activists artists
designers architects entrepreneurs
you name it we want to include the ideas
and perspectives of
all ages and all backgrounds
and finally we don't want to limit this
just to the european union that's why
i'm thrilled
to see impressive names from the united
states
from australia from asia on our speakers
list
when we asked for contributions during
the design
phase of the project we also asked about
the needs to make transformation happen
and surprisingly only a minority of
people mentioned
funding first the vast majority
underlined the importance of networking
and connecting
the right people today
at this conference we can contribute to
this evolving
new european bauhaus network
and i'm impressed to see the interest
and the ideas this project has already
sparked
over 5 000 participants took part in the
first
info sessions organized by the european
commission
we saw dozens of events and discussions
in many member states from croatia
to finland from slovenia
to spain hundreds of contributions
were posted via the new european bauhaus
website
or in portugal three ministries are
working with
architects and designers on their vision
of a new european bauhaus
linked to the sea
in poland organizations are looking into
possibilities
to combine the new european bauhaus
with the transformation of the coal
regions
and we are particularly thankful for the
huge interest and support from the
european parliament
and the committee of the regions thanks
to all of you this project
is a project of hope it's a project of
change and of economic transformation
this also means funding
tomorrow we will launch the first
edition of the new european bauhaus
prize
commissioner gabrielle and commissioner
ferreira
will give you all the details tomorrow
we want to celebrate those who have
already created inspiring examples
for the new european bauhaus in autumn
we will launch the call for the first
five pilot projects it will include a
seat funding of
25 million euros and the possibility to
combine this with money from the
structural funds
and more calls will follow so i hope
that this conference can contribute
further
to making the transformation happen and
to connecting
more and more people who want to make it
happen and i'm looking forward to the
discussions
so thank you very much and have a great
conference
thank you very much to the president of
the european commission for this
inspiring
opening speech and as you've heard this
is going to be
a very strategic and important program
to shape the the future of europe to
make it more sustainable
and more inclusive and that's why we
have the absolute privilege today
to have with us the president of the
european parliament
david sassoli and we expect